est-ce que je peux vous mettre un petit
test
votre relation avec les participes
passées ça ressemble à quoi
si je vous dis la pomme est tombée par
terre comment vous écrivez tomber
ait tomber et avec la pomme avec
[Musique]
la femme non si ça prend un mur je pense
comme c'est
le verbe
le participe passé d'un verbe conjugué
avec être ça corde effectivement en
genre et en nombre avec le sujet donc la
pomme est tombée e accent aigu si je
vous dis la pomme que Luc a acheté est
délicieuse acheter vous l'écrivez
comment ah comme c'est écrit maintenant
ça va pas changer acheter c'est juste
l'accent aigu parce que c'est avec le
verbe avoir dans ce cas-ci comme le
complément direct pomme est avant le
participe passé conjugué avec avoir il
s'accorde en genre et en nombre donc
acheter e accent aigu elle s'est blessée
en coupant une pomme blessée vous
l'écrivez comment
eux à la fin
parce que moi je suis en train de penser
à ce qu'on m'a dit de faire quand il y a
le verbe être elle est blessée blessée
qui s'est blessé ou quoi comme le
complément il doit venir
ici on a un verbe pronominal ce qui fait
que le participe passé s'accorde en
genre et en nombre avec le complément
direct parce qu'il est placé avant donc
blesser un accent aigu et la dernière
des pommes j'en ai mangé manger vous
l'écrivez comment
c'est comme ça comme ça parce que c'est
avant avant l'auxiliaire avoir manger
avec seulement le accent aigu est
effectivement la bonne réponse mais
c'est parce que le complément direct et
le pronom en le participe passé reste
alors généralement invariable j'ai
toujours trouvé le français difficile à
cause de ça il faut avoir une très bonne
mémoire pour se souvenir des exceptions
faudrait savoir c'est qui qui a décidé
que ça s'écrivait comme ça déjà puis se
demander quels étaient de la raison pour
moi c'est juste pour nous embêter déjà
en 2014 le Conseil international de la
langue française proposait de simplifier
les règles d'accord du participe passé
l'Association québécoise des professeurs
de français appuient et propose une
réforme au ministère de l'Éducation et
réforme de simplification sont bonnes
puis le monde ils sont trop à cheval sur
les règles de français je pense qu'il
oublie que le français c'est du latin
bâcler en fait c'est la profondeur de de
la langue française tout simplement il
faut pas les changer c'est apprendre ou
à laisser tout simplement voilà